[Music]
when you are running a business you are
always searching for new ways to create
fresh source of revenue i created one
for my business last year while
launching a cloud consultancy services
all while learning a course from
simplylearn
hi i am ravin kumarjala i live in mumbai
and i am the co-founder and chief
digital and technology officer of vcns
global
we specialize in providing security
solutions i.t review and overall
consultancy in technology sectors
when you are working with the global
players like marriott hyatt hilton
oberoi and taj you have to take care of
all their needs i wanted to cater to
customers who wanted to take the journey
towards the cloud so i decided to opt
for the post graduation program in cloud
computing in association with caltech
from simplylearn
and while i was doing this course i
started my cloud consultancy services
so i was learning every day and
implementing my learning at my business
too in real time
our customers usually don't know whether
they want to opt in for public cloud or
a private cloud or azure or google or a
data center so we study their business
and suggest which cloud service would
suit them best
after i completed the course i was able
to structure the whole cloud consultancy
vertical for my company we have added
seven cloud consultancy customers
i think it was a wise decision to take
the course
i could actually take the time out to
study because the course was flexible i
could access course videos on my phone
so my work did not suffer so that's how
easy it is
even for people working at a senior
level like me
at that level you must devote your time
to learn new things to improve
efficiency in business time is money
so make a wise investment today
[Music]